what a reject nation Greg's back with
John today hi
we're gonna watch the not the winning
the future the Christopher Robin movie
yeah Christopher Robin story no not at
all actually it's more of the sequel to
who would either poop let's just watch
it let's see what marc forster director
of world wars ESO operas
[Music]
mr. Porter has called an emergency
meeting this weekend I promised my wife
and daughter I'd take them away this
weekend sir we need to cut 20% you were
promised these people good jobs don't
off you do anything to this company
[Music]
a lot of [ __ ] most of your favorite
movie
all these remakes
[Music]
a few wrinkles maybe I was now I know
John was a big winnie-the-pooh fan
growing up I kind of watched Winnie the
Pooh growing up I grew up with like the
books and the audiobooks and then and
then later on the Disney stuff looking
at this trailer they said doesn't feel
like I just some direct remake of some
Disney animated material already well
they've already done that I mean they
made like an animated like a hand-drawn
Winnie the Pooh a few years exact yeah
yeah and it was supposed to be good but
I don't think it made like a heap ton of
money and this feels like it's directly
out of whatever new phase they're doing
a nice reminds me kind of of the Mary
Poppins trailer yesterday I thought it
was gonna be more like the feeling of
the hook movie when I heard the synopsis
for this terms of Christopher Robin's
all grown up now and he kind of lost
some of his imagination this seems to be
taking that schizophrenic approach
actually this feels more like some weird
psychological break Christopher Robin in
his when he's an adult he's struggling
he's poor and now he's gone crazy I
thought it was gonna be like some weird
hybrid animation film for some reason I
didn't realize it was gonna be like oh
the toys are being brought to life which
is cool that maybe like a sweeter
version of Ted yeah something like that
he's environment I'm sure it's not
actually gonna be the schizophrenic
approach you know yeah a fantasy and
it's cool they got Jim Cummings to come
back to play Pooh Bear yeah yeah I
didn't I didn't realize that it happened
until he spoke for the first time in my
heart kind of wept you know I think
these effects on him of the tea's we got
looks really good I don't know how
appealing it's gonna be for everyone
because we're all so used to like the
animated one and then the animated toys
of that this looks a little bit more
along the lines of what the actual ever
/ Robin Hood he was a kid I think that's
kind of a cool idea in concept I'm
definitely intrigued by what this is it
certainly wasn't exactly what I was
expecting it to be it makes sense if
this trailer would come out like right
after the Mary Poppins Returns trailer -
yeah very similar I feel like these are
out of the same phase of whatever yeah
trying to do right now yeah they're both
treated as a sequel - and similar to
Mary Poppins both of these stories are
about the kids and then when they're
grown up and they reencounter yeah their
childhood friend that kind of felt like
a fantasy you know yeah yes and it seems
like both in times of hardship yeah when
they return to us to help us you know
getting back in touch with something I'm
a little more cautious about this just
because it's a bit like taller of an
order for me to swallow it feels more
mature like that whole first like minute
seemed like this is like real drama yeah
yeah and I mean you know hearing a
little bit about like what the real
Christopher Robin's life was like later
on I'm also curious to how this fits
into the real story because it doesn't
seem like he was super thrilled later on
in life about Winnie the Pooh yeah and
this Marc Forster version feels more
like the Finding Neverland spirituals
sequel to that yeah what do you guys
think of this Christopher Robin trailer
you excited it's Annie more Christopher
Robin based I can't wait to see all the
other animals yeah yeah yes you're gonna
show up yeah that's you yeah depressive
disorder yeah Christopher Robin
schizophrenic
jiggers attention hyperactive is over
yeah yeah and then you know who has an
eating disorder and piglet is a social
anxiety all right guys well you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Rella get notified every
time one of our vids is up and you can
check us out on patreon weekly Q&A is
full-length music video and TV show
reactions over there including shows
such as I'm doing attack on Titan we're
doing my hero I could be me together I'm
covered in the flash we're doing black
lighting together he's doing Riverdale
he's thinking to cover in Atlanta right
now there's a whole bunch of stuff from
doing over there so go over there
check us out we'd love to have you